Batman Arkham Knigge death time and
again I've been asked to review the
Arkham games in the retrospective series
but I've always kind of had one reason
or another not to so I said anything to
negative people will get angry if I was
too positive the review would sound
biased and boring besides these are
really popular games and damn near
everyone has talked about this series in
the past what could I say that hasn't
been said already yes they nailed it
with Arkham Asylum
it's the perfect Batman video game plus
they even came back around for a solid
follow up with Arkham City and Arkham
origins wasn't necessarily bad but felt
kind of like filler for the real third
game then we get to the stunning
conclusion in which this series closes
with a bang they'll finally answer all
the questions we've had it'll go in a
bold new direction while also paying
homage to all that came before it and
definitively close the loop in a way
that leaves fans breathless except this
one wasn't really that this one just
kind of had problems like a lot of
problems other than the unplayable PC
release debacle no one really reacted
negatively to this one game critics were
all positive but people on the internet
and Friends I had who likes a series all
went dark it's like the game came out
and then everyone just stopped saying
anything unless it was their literal job
to do so maybe a few people complain
that the dlc episodes were short and
didn't have any free roam
some people said that the Batmobile was
a little overwhelming or some people
just said that getting the ending was a
pain in the ass I feel like this game
deserves more than just a few mumbles in
the crowd of other [ __ ] going on in 2015
there's a lot to talk about here
primarily that this one was kind of
disappointing ok controversial statement
it's not as much of a letdown as no man
sky was there anything but this
certainly didn't feel like it was up to
the quality standard of gameplay and
storytelling the other two and a half
games had now I know a lot of people are
already hearing to climb up my ass about
not liking this one because
diehard fans are called that for a
reason but please hear me out first if I
haven't convinced you that this wasn't a
good closure for the series by the end
of the video I'll practically give you
the car seriously though I don't want it
you can have it
so there's a lot to sort through and
taking out a game this complex is a
little intimidating but I think the best
place to start looking is to figure out
what made the rest of the series so
great now Batman has had a long history
of video games and what I like to refer
to as attempt at video games but if seem
like the idea was just never going to
work
x-men and Avengers game seemed to work
out nicely for Raven software and
Spiderman was practically the face of
the superhero game genre because the
major competitors hadn't really come
onto the scene yet then 2009 came along
and after two whole years of development
and programming Batman's cape finally
looked pretty good and the other stuff
in that game was alright too but that
[ __ ] tape was awesome the first thing
that stuck out to me when I played it as
a wee lad was that it was an original
story but it felt like it could totally
just be one of the comics it could also
just be a continuation of the animated
series I watched in a toddler I
immediately loved that this story was
solid enough on its own that it really
felt like it could be used in the can
and a boat it gave a sense of
authenticity in the story was more
engaging because of it the gameplay was
nothing short of a miracle either
because they pretty much had to reinvent
the wheel with these mechanics the
combat was something we had never seen
before except in spider-man 2 and the
stealth gameplay made you feel like you
are Batman you had such a wealth of
weird gadgets to toss a shirtless
criminal and the more went on the more
visibly you could see them freaking out
because you picked them off one by one
like the predator naturally I sucked at
this in 2009 because I was in like
fourth grade or something but I still
had fun trying to figure it out
this along with infamous and prototype
really shook up the superhero action
genre and people have been trying to
build them based off of these examples
ever since but how do you continue to
innovate when you change the game and
become the gold standard for superhero
games
well the sequel comes out and just adds
cool stuff they didn't have time for in
the first one open-world elements
scripted side missions with cool extra
plots additional story stuff that also
has free roam which is an enormous plot
and a story that was hinted at in the
last one so this feel
like to a well-thought-out series but
the next two games felt like they had no
idea where to go and had to make it up
on the spot good this one will be a
prequel to fill for time so drop it on a
smaller developer with less money and
have them marketed purely with the fact
that the voice cast is different despite
sounding pretty much the same now for
this one well we could um you see we
just on that story also feels completely
disconnected from the previous one in
terms of its villains scarecrow is
almost a completely different character
now for some reason and the arkham
knight himself was sold to us as someone
who would have witnessed the event of
the previous two games someone that had
been there all along getting ready to
shut Batman down and holy hell was it a
cool idea for them to invent a new
villain native to this series of games
nobody has done that before with a
superhero game that I know of
of course all this was lies to hype up
the story before release I remember a
lot of people speculating on characters
in this series that it could have been
perhaps it was a fear toxin induced
mirror image of Batman where he sees a
version of himself as a gun-wielding
monster that takes over the city and
hardly innocent would be the first time
Batman battles a ghost of his own
imagination seeing is out every single
installment features a fight like that
maybe they had something to do with the
warden who is possessed by a ghost from
the first game if it isn't actually an
original character maybe it could have
even been Joker himself coming back
alongside Clayface they were working
together to restore the status quo by
making a grand parody of Batman and
throwing the city in the chaos and again
people who have never read a Batman
comic in their life and only know the
characters through quick glances at
Wikipedia could stare at this and say
it's obviously you know who which don't
worry we'll get back to that then
everyone else including myself went into
the stage of denial saying there's no
way that would be way too easy and make
no sense
this sentence being horribly prophetic
of things to come
yeah shits gonna go down in next game
really really now well thanks for
letting us all know who would again
people are probably wondering aside from
the lying before the release and
predictable twist what is it really that
earthly so much about this game I don't
even know where to start I've written in
a racist paragraph five times there is
so much wrong with this game maybe we'll
just start with something simple the
gameplay Arkham Knight takes the
gameplay ideas we loved from previous
games and applies them to about one hour
of this game then spend the entire rest
of the game in the Batmobile now fans
were begging for the Batmobile to be
playable for years before this came out
and Rocksteady listened what fans didn't
ask for was that the majority of the
game take place in a vehicle that is
essentially an 18-ton dismiss you
Oh
it's pretty much the main mechanic of
the game
everything that Batman has been able to
do reliably on his own for three games
now requires the use of the Batmobile
remember running across rooftops gliding
around using the grapple hook to scale
tall buildings that is behavior that
feels actively discouraged now every
mission finds a way to force you back
into the things I also can't begin to
explain how stupid it is that all of
Riddler's traps require you to use the
car in some capacity we have three
entries in this series who's genuinely
mind boggling puzzles complicated
challenges using the game physics or
sometimes complex death traps that make
jigsaw look like jigsaw I was one of
those masochist who solved every single
riddle in all three games and now
Riddler is so tapped for idea that he's
resorted to just making a giant
racetrack this is the ultimate test of
your intelligence a [ __ ] racetrack
that lets you do over if you don't make
the time limit not good enough to slow
detective are you kidding me
[Music]
what is held but never kept the hostages
are as good as dead Dark Knight and
there's nothing you can do about it what
is too tired but never needs rest
you'll never be smart enough to get this
one Dark Knight give enigma I'll play
your game and I'll save those hostages
doc get the hostages oh no no no no no
you can start over again take as much
time as you need
you'll never be smiling after this
no this is impossible you should have
done this to Satan Crimmins
nygma I in the superior intellect I am
smart enough to go in a line without
dying I was smart enough lemon riddle a
dangerous deathtrap
I even defeated your treacherous track I
am the Batman but the message is that
anyone can be the mad man except I'm a
better Batman theoretically than anyone
else would be because I'm a billionaire
but still it's off that counts and
really anyone can do in the end as long
as they just have their hearts in the
right place except dad's really kind of
[ __ ] sucked at you know what I mean
oh god damn it
so came here you play all the other
effort I'm proud of you for trying
hey man account high winner is owning
the time of day so many aspects of the
world make zero sense in order to excuse
for the Batmobiles numerous logistical
problems let me ask you this with the
Arkham Knight knowing as much about
Batman as he does would he not have come
up with a better way to manipulate
Batman and you're doing what everyone
else does and throwing a million grunts
at him the entire city is being ruled by
unmanned tanks that are presumably
operated by some guy at a budget laptop
but what if they're all individually
piloted by the militia members Batman
can't blow them up with missiles and
bullets now because of the no killing
rule or better yet just high random
civilians to the tops of the tank that
way you don't have to train 200 people
to drive these things either way the
story making more sense
suddenly tramples on the gameplay
because you can't have epic tank battles
unless they're unmanned and Batman
shooting an EMP cannon doesn't exactly
sound as appealing people watch shooting
apparently
every minor gameplay sequence in
previous games is now handled with the
bat tank following a trail of clues that
leads you to the bad guys doing the tank
puzzles with a grapple hook do it in the
tank even the [ __ ] stunt sequences do
it in the tank
why does everyone say the gameplay is
good this borders on being hilarious
because they actually have you sneaking
around in your giant missile launching
car hiding from even bigger missile
launching vehicles did no-one else think
this was silly
[Music]
what's up [ __ ] I'm here to stock up
on robbing I keep running out lately I
mean it would be fine if the Batmobile
combat was at least fun but it's just
irritating and it feels like it's there
a consume your time the gameplay with it
basically boils down to sitting
perfectly still and waiting for the
other vehicles to lock onto you then you
just lazily slide to a different
direction and they can't hit you it's
boring because it's so hard to fail and
it's not very demanding in terms of
strategy everyone else just sits
perfectly still and waits politely for
you to move out of their firing path as
long as you shoot at the obvious glowing
weak spots on these things the second
you see them they may never even get a
hit in it's especially embarrassing when
you put them in a close quarters area
and just Massacre them it's good to know
the main enemy type of the game can only
be threatening if the player falls
asleep at the control which might
actually happen even that girl sounds
disinterested in the tank battle ok
setbacks started damn people have
prepared
kidnap me kidnap my god you'll pay after
that nation eminent ok everybody
remember where we parked all right
there's also the numerous paradoxes that
go along with every game where a player
is allowed to drive their own car we
hadn't learned from many other games
decades ago already the lesson is that
you can't give enough people the ability
to drive around however they want with
no penalty they will drive over anything
that isn't on the road just for the hell
of it vehicular manslaughter is a bit
out of character for Bruce however so
the entire city is devoid of civilians
in every person on the street is counted
as an enemy who most likely deserve to
get run over so let's put an electricity
effect on them to imply the car just
tase them and said slaughtering them I
don't need to tell you that being hit by
a Taser the size of two lanes of traffic
going 90 miles an hour isn't going to
just knock you unconscious you know what
let's go do some nice non-lethal street
justice in this thing
my man
[Music]
when Gotham lighting ruined my life
[Music]
[Music]
my file jingles I don't blame you
oh don't worry those guys will be fine
it was a non-lethal crushing oh my god
his pelvis what I think I'm a monster I
get that they were catering to fans with
the Batmobile but from a gameplay and
story perspective it just doesn't work
every single aspect of its inclusion in
the game makes everything around it make
his little sense as possible I think the
game would have absolutely been better
if they just didn't use it or at the
very least
use it once like that uncharted mission
oh thank god it's gone
ha take down you steel plated
incongruity I guess you're the flat
mobile now don't worry we just made a
sale oh come on now in defenses of that
mobile if it were used in any other game
in any other context and way more
sparingly you'll be pretty [ __ ] cool
it feels good to drive around it's fun
to smash through scenery at top speed
and chase helpless cars with it and as
stupid as the Riddler races are they're
pretty fun to do in the challenge mode
the problem is that it's all in this
game and it just doesn't sit here at all
this Lincoln is the ultimate [ __ ]
[ __ ] outrage of sports ever it's so
[ __ ] stupid
what they what they did was to spend
time ready for four days for not giving
him his [ __ ] cell phone that's and
for having a friend who called himself a
deflator if I got in trouble for all the
things that my friends called themselves
yeah it would be finished okay maybe Tom
Brady so [ __ ] classy and such a
[ __ ] gentleman that he doesn't want
people to know that he may have
reflected on his real opinion of some of
his co-workers well like guys he plays
with guys he plays against his real
feelings
I wouldn't want guys who I didn't think
we're very good to know I didn't think
they were very good I wouldn't want guys
who I I thought were great to know I
thought they were great I want my to
keep my opinions to myself we haven't
done anything to address this crisis and
domestic violence in the NFL but the
[ __ ] football better not be 8% light
if we find out it is you go out for game
he ever notice how all these games one
of Batman's arms is way bigger than the
other I mean I think it makes sense I
guess just a little weird to include so
the Batmobile is basically a giant
rolling lock cause for this game what
about the traditional gameplay segment
well I guess if there's anything I must
praise its that the combat is at its
best it's so satisfying to take out a
room full of a dozen bad guys without
breaking the combo it's challenging
enough that you can screw it up but with
practice you feel like such a badass the
only major additions are the use of
environmental objects in the inclusion
of weapons that you can pick up if
you've ever wanted to see Batman smash
through a room full of people with a
baseball bat here you go
depending on where you're at in the
story you might also have another
character along for the ride and you can
switch to playing as them in the middle
of combat they even give you a team take
down this is a really cool improvement
and it makes for an interesting way for
Batman to interact with characters from
the bat family which is a nice change of
pace considering how he's been alone for
every game until now there's also the
addition of enemies that can get back up
or be revived by their teammates they
can you have to consider which ones are
most important to take out first
I guess the riddles in this one are
pretty much the standard fare for indoor
section and I have the same love-hate
relationship with them that I've always
had ah [ __ ]
I am super colorblind well yes I'm going
to be here for a while now something
previous Arkham games law has been
praised for is the self gameplay in
which Batman has x-ray vision that you
might forget to turn off after a while
be honest you played at least 80% of
Arkham Asylum with every NPC being a
glowing skeleton Arkham Asylum City and
origins all had a lot of work put into
the level design surrounding these
stealth sequences and they offered a lot
of variety to the way you could
suffocate buff shirtless men with your
bulky leather gloves arguably one of arc
of nice biggest missteps is that the
stealth areas are kind of poorly
designed the majority of the floor is
covered in the Grace and you might end
up spending every single one of these
segments just hiding in the ground and
waiting to nab people almost all of
these sequences take place outside and
in the open air on rooftop so the amount
of tactics you can use in places you can
hide are generally really limited this
is probably because the game has maybe
four substantial levels that take place
indoors the rest are short side missions
or DLC stuff for the main campaign the
stealth usually sucks however in the
side missions they give you areas that
are actually well-thought-out and
require you to really strategize again
the best example is probably being the
two-face bank robbery missions these
areas are some of the best in the game
because you don't spend most of them
waiting around under the floorboards
like at that press trapdoor spider
the only real addition to any of the
stealth gameplay is one new mechanic the
fear multi takedown basically a big loud
slow-motion super move that you can do
to layout multiple guys at once you can
upgrade it to effect five people at a
time very early in the game it only
takes one stealth takedown to charge it
up so in the stealth gameplay the devs
gave you a mechanic that basically
discourages you from being stealthy and
requires essentially
no strategy at all what a great idea
next you'll be giving us a cheat button
during the puzzle sequences in case they
get too hard for everyone do you do a
lot of work for Riddler only when you're
not looking okay the boss fights haven't
been a strong point for the Arkham
series a lot of them in the first game
really just boiled down to jumping out
of the way while a big guy runs at you
then wait till he gets stuck in a wall
or gets tired or something and they go
wail on him the second game improved
with that awesome fight with Solomon
Grundy and the cell sequence against mr.
freeze now while the game as a whole
wasn't the best Arkham origins even had
some really good ones like fire flying
super Vayne don't even try to tell me
that ninja battle with Deathstroke
wasn't cool now you got tank Deathstroke
is in this game too and his boss fight
is a tank battle we went from this to
this
this isn't even a unique encounter it's
just a repeat of the Arkham night boss
fight with a different voice shouting
generic bad guy dialogue at you you know
what let's run down this as quickly as
possible
Firefly is in this game and you beat him
by just following them around until his
jetpack runs out of gas for the first
time in a row a professional boxer
because infected with a virus that turns
them into the Joker and his fight is
really more of just a QuickTime event
than anything else you can defeat
man-bat by just hopping on it back three
times in various segments of the game
the Riddler is not a character you
should ever have to fight because it's
beneath his character but he has a big
dumb robot that you'll never have the
patients achieve except ugly two-face is
pretty much just a reskin of a normal
enemy Titan can be dealt with as such
Harley Quinn is pretty much just a
reskin of a normal enemy Titan can be
dealt with his son
yeah the bosses are all kind of
non-existent
hey the city looks great Knoll but isn't
it a little strange that Gotham City is
composed of five separate islands in the
middle of a Bay and Wayne Manor isn't on
any of them does that mean that Batman
actually lives in like blood Haven or
according to the movies metropolis now
this entire review so far has been
devoted to rounding up all the poor
design choices or just general logical
fallacies and that's really just me
stalling for time because I was
genuinely afraid to talk about this game
story not because the story is vague or
absent it's that every individual
component of it makes me furious because
I have such high hopes for it
I'd say this game boasts storytelling on
par with the Star Wars prequels nothing
makes sense
every character suddenly decides to act
like a [ __ ] everyone is scuttling
around the city doing things for flimsy
or transparent reasons and the villains
of the game are once again overshadowed
by good old mr. J of all the bad guys to
bring back why not any of these guys I
mean
Clayface fell into the lazarus pit and
you're gonna tell me that had no strange
effect on any of his powers he just died
the comic book game for God's sake that
setup was so easy
remember that tiny subplot from Arkham
City about Harley having joke
baby and then losing it not even gonna
attempt to follow up on that one anyway
let's begin with Joker's involvement in
this story